[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Don Saki on today we have the
pleasure of sitting down with dr. Robin
Hanson hello Robin thanks for joining us
today
hi there you didn't tell me I should
wear colorful socks haha
the pink socks with police nothing I
could have done that I have such socks
but you do tell me well we can't see
your socks from this angle I would I
wouldn't care I would lift them up just
to show you lift them up just I'm thank
you for tuning in all the way from
Virginia thank you
so for those that don't know Robin is
been a professor of economics at George
Mason University for 19 years
holy cow that is a long time to be
professing and teaching young students
about the importance of economics across
environment and health and law and all
these fields you know when you've been
in a place that long you don't usually
think about it all the time so when
somebody mentions it you go oh yeah I
guess so yeah yeah and that's so many
kids that have went through your hands
and you've expanded their minds to these
new dimensions I love teaching in that
sense and learning we you've also been
the chief scientist at consensus point
now for 10 years which is focused on
prediction market research I'm excited
to talk to you about that and then your
van your author of two books the age of
M and then also the elephant in the
brain and that's your newest book yeah
there it is elf in the brain which
focuses on the the under the non
acknowledged
features of how our mind works
especially things like selfishness which
I'm really excited to chat about as well
so oh yeah and also research associate
at the future of humanity Institute at
Oxford so this is a very very big
background I'm super excited what what
got you what got you into all of this
where were you born and then how did you
really develop until you were like 22
and deciding that like what you wanted
to do in life I was pretty young and
nerdy so I you know was into my own head
and thinking about things in college I
guess it was diagnostic that I took the
first two years of physics taking the
regular classes and then the second two
years of physics was all the same topics
with but with more math and I was
unhappy with that so at that point I
took the strategy of stopping homework
and just acing the exams in the semester
I would just play with the equations all
semester so that I guess was the first
time I really deviated from the standard
plan and decided to do things my way and
then what led you to the PhD in social
science from Cal Tech well that was a
long trajectory because I went to grad
school and social in philosophy of
science and then I did physics and I got
two masters in those and then I spent
nine years as a computer researcher and
then I went back to school and Social
Sciences so I had spent a long time out
of school and finally went back to
school at the age of 34 with two kids a
zero and two oh my goodness and so you
went you did some AI research at Ames
and Lockheed and like yeah and then you
came back to do the PhD when he had kids
crazy right so that was a long detour
perhaps and then you started did you
start professing right after then the
PhD well I four years in your out PhD
which was good for someone older like me
so it didn't take ten years for the PhD
and then I did a two-year postdoc at
Berkeley and then I got my tenure-track
position at George Mason and I've been
and so what are some of these main
Eureka moments for you as you've been
teaching economics to the students I
don't know that I have Eureka moments in
teaching exactly or or or what are the
Eureka moments that you've been teaching
the students so that their minds get
expanded to all these new dimensions of
economics I like to teach the standard
methods but then apply them to unusual
topics yeah I there are people out there
who are eager to focus on unusual
methods or unusual you know general
claims I'm more happy to apply the usual
methods and even the usual claims to
unusual applications and so I teach say
law and economics or health economics
and I like to you know have the students
try to apply these concepts to two
topics where their emotions might just
jump out and say of course this is the
answer and but they have to do is set
aside their emotions and work through
the analysis to find out what the theory
says yeah give us an example of one
that's your favorite or one of your
favorites
well blackmail for example most people
immediate intuition is of course
blackmail is a bad idea but in basic law
and economics the usual analysis we'd
apply would suggest it's actually a good
idea
and so then you try to you know make the
students work that through
I mean that doesn't mean it actually is
a good idea it just means their standard
simple theories suggest it's a good idea
and that's worth people thinking about I
mean another example is that prison is
really quite inefficient and maybe we
should be using more torture or exile
and so there's straightforward arguments
oh my good yeah
but of course people find that difficult
to think about so that those are good
examples because they're very
economically makes sense that the
torturer exile er or or even death
penalty and it's economically seems it
costs thirty five thousand a year well
however much to house a person in summer
is seventy thousand really seven zero
thousand yeah other than wait oh my gosh
and knows that much so so these are the
examples when in blackmail as well the
idea is that you can increase your
economic flourishing if you choose to
blackmail the opponent of your come of
the company that go well yeah in
blackmail the idea is more that the
kinds of things people would be
blackmailed for are things that look bad
to a wider world and therefore the
prospect of being blackmail would
discourage people from doing the things
that would then look bad so if on
average you think the people the things
that people get blackmailed for aren't
good things to be doing ie crime or
cheating on the relationships or
cheating on their companies etc then
blackmail would be more effective at
discouraging those things so blackmail
would be more effective at discouraging
a company for a chief of a company from
cheating on the company so if maybe
you're starting to get Inklings that
they are cheating on the company then
you could blackmail them by saying hey
we have records about you cheating on
company stop doing it and then that
would be effective at stopping it the
the threat of that would be effective so
yeah you know years ago that one of the
most recent famous applications of
blackmail law was Letterman he was you
know having affairs with some of his
co-workers at the office and somebody
threatened to blackmail him about that
and then he brought that to the police
and that person was convicted of
blackmail but of course in general if
you expected that people could get away
with blackmail then you would be more
wary of cheating at the office because
you
anticipate that somebody might therefore
successfully blackmail you and then
you'd have to pay money and you don't
want to pay money so maybe you'd do it
less yes yes okay I can I can see how
these examples are there in many ways
most people don't think about them and
so that's always good to highlight
things that most people don't think
about so that's good that you have that
you've been doing that so what about all
of this work in prediction market
research so you started or you you have
this idea this idea futures the
information prize can you explain for us
yeah sure so the idea is that a lot of
things that go wrong in our world are
because we make the wrong choices and
that's often because we have the wrong
information but as we misjudge the
consequences of our actions now we have
many institutions that are supposedly
there for the purpose of helping us to
get better information about our
decisions we have juries we have news
media we have academia and we have
special commissions etc and these
institutions that are supposedly
producing better information could be
even better if they worked better
and so prediction markets are a
institution that have been around for a
long time that we can show actually work
quite well at producing accurate
estimates so it's basically a betting
market but you can use betting markets
to create accurate information on a lot
of topics so for example say you have a
project and you're in an organization it
might be a company and you're wondering
whether you'll make your deadline on the
project and there are many ways to
collect information about whether you
make the deadline you might have
committee meeting you might survey the
various people related to the project
you might hire a statistical consulting
firm to come in and analyze projects
like this but still often you have the
scenario where people think they're
going to make the deadline and then they
don't and a lot of things go wrong
because of that so one thing you can do
instead is to just create a betting
market on whether you're gonna make the
deadline and allow people who know about
the project nor related to it to just
get involved in that betting market and
bet anonymously
so that they can say bad news through
the betting market without being
retaliated against in the rest of their
social life and it turns out that works
very well you can find out much more
accurately than you usually do through
other means whether your projects going
to make a deadline by having a betting
market on that project
so the general scenario is you know
there's something we all want to know
because it might be useful ie will we
make a deadline and then there are these
various mechanisms we tend to use that
we say we are using to find out whether
it will make the deadline and then
there's this new institution or it's
actually an old one that a newly you
know a set of interest in a betting
market that actually systems you know
consistently does a good and better job
of estimating this thing that we want
information on and that's the positive
pitch for prediction markets it is to
say look you say you want to know this
and here's the thing that tells you and
so go for it and it turns out not only
are these betting markets consistently
more accurate they are relatively cheap
they're you know robust they work on a
wide range of topics and they're
actually especially resistant to
manipulation that is hard to make them
distort distort into to distort their
estimates because there are processes
that come back and correct on that
so then putting a betting market on the
way that people are behaving can give
you better insight into how that
collective is going to actually behave
well it works on not just behavior but a
wide very wide range of topics you might
want information on but of course yes
most of topics we want information on
are have people involved and people's
behavior is relevant so yes some of the
unique insights from the prediction
market research well in my mind the most
interesting questions are involving why
we don't actually use them much the
barriers to application and the
obstacles and the reasons why people are
less interested than they say now there
have been whole streams of research on
how to make these more effective and
cheap and we've done a lot of that so
we've had you know studying manipulation
and how well that
work we've study how to have lots of
more markets cheaply how to have
billions of markets with lots of
overlapping prices that you can estimate
quickly you know how to have sensible
user interfaces how to subsidize trading
there's a lot of things that researchers
have worked but mostly this is creating
a big pile of technology that isn't used
and so we could continue in that
direction to make more and more more
elaborate cheaper more effective
technology that doesn't get used but
when it's hardly being used I think the
key question is well why not what's
going on and that's related to the theme
of the second book here the elephant and
the brain hidden motives in everyday
life
I think the key way to understand
prediction markets use is to say they
are designed to give us a thing we tend
to say we want and we don't actually
want it as much as we say mmhmm
yeah maybe a a good example of that is
how many people tend to overestimate
their willingness to contribute to the
collective or to be somebody that stands
up to do something people tend to say
that they will do something well if a
part time time comes to it they choose
not to sure I mean when people watch a
war movie they think of themselves I
would be the hero they watch a movie
about an activist and they say I would
have stand up and marched and resisted
all this opposition because I would have
known it's true and of course on average
that isn't what most people are like
awesome is does would you say that I
mean all of your work kind of represents
this idea of you quakes and right before
we get to the books I I kind of want to
talk about the view quakes because I
think they're sure that's so interesting
because many people we tend on the show
to say like we're expanding people's
minds to new areas of thought and we
view quake is to go ahead and explain
well so just to say conversation like
what we're having now if you ask people
what it's for
they will say it's to share information
that's the point of conversation and if
you ask you know what would be the point
of sharing information it would be to
influence decisions and because of that
the most valuable information to share
would be information that's relevant to
our most important decisions ie on
important topics yeah and also
information that was very surprising and
has wide scope so a view cake can be
thought as as something you learned that
was you know not at all what you
expected and that has a wide scope it
changes how you think about many things
now if what you really wanted was more
information then you should be
especially interested in that kind of
information you would be of course even
more interesting view crakes on the most
important topics but it's noteworthy
that most people aren't really that
interested or eager for view quakes and
most conversation doesn't really focus
on surprising conclusions and most of
our media and academia doesn't put a
especially large premium on especially
surprising conclusions so we tend to be
wary of those in practice even though
according to what we say we should be
more interested
their people's lives and I try and have
even asked them questions that will then
insa gave you quakes in my life from
listening to them so I have this play
with information I whenever I interact
with people I try and get really deep
with people as fast as possible that way
I can have as many view quakes as
possible right you'll want to be talking
about important topics but you'll also
want to be you know looking at the
weakest points and looking for the
biggest ways to your views could change
what what are the you know standard
points of view where there are
suspicious doubts ways they seem weaker
than they should be and diving to ask
well could that just be wrong yeah yes
now okay so how did you how did you go
into writing about the age of M this is
work love life when robots rule earth so
doing what they like doing things like
scanning the human brain and then
running that as an emulation inside of a
robot how did you how did you get into
that into this field and then now what
is the essence of that piece of writing
so there's two elements of that origin
story one is that many years ago when I
was a software engineer in Silicon
Valley I hang out with futurists people
who think about the future who like
science fiction and there at the time
into nanotechnology and cyberpunks and
things like that and in that world of
course people are very interested in the
future but they're very focused on
technology driven futures and most of
them don't know much social science and
in that world they don't tend to think
science social science exists that's
certainly what I was taught when I was
an undergraduate in physics basically
one way or another we were taught those
people over and the social science
buildings they're making it up they
don't know anything
true sciences over here and everything
else is just a mirage and so the world
of people projecting the future is full
of people thinking about different
technologies and then mostly making up
the social implications because they
don't think there's any way to be an
expert about that and so many years ago
when I was a graduate student of
first year I was a student the first
Christmas vacation I spent a few days
writing up this article applying my
first semesters tools in economics to
this unusual science fiction scenario of
brain emulation and I wrote this paper
called if uploads come first and then
that sat in the background as I went and
did other things and I always hope
somebody would do more on that but I you
know was trying to get tenure etc and
the second part of the story is that
eventually I got tenure and then I
enjoyed the freedom of tenure to explore
a lot of things I started blogging and I
wrote you know the in the habit of
writing a few paragraphs on a new topic
and I'm thinking I have an insight there
and then going on at the next topic
which is very satisfying
but then I worried if I want to have a
legacy maybe I need to focus and do a
book or two because a book is the sort
of thing that can last longer and people
focus yes and so I asked what should I
write a book on and at that point I
basically had all these intellectual
children who I loved and I was facing
the prospect that basically starving all
but one to focus on really feeding that
one and yeah and so how could I focus on
just one of these many you know
beautiful children and so my strategy
was to pick the topic that was most
engrossing not necessarily the most
important or the ones where I had the
deepest insight or the most to offer but
the one with the most fascinating detail
such that it would just pull me in and
my mind would be in that world thinking
about that topic and so I chose the
brain emulation topic for that purpose
that is the basic question is if we
eventually have brain emulation which we
can summarize in a moment how does the
world change so I've run around
conversations on this topic for many
decades and when the topic comes up you
usually talk about is it even possible
when might have happened which enabling
technology would would create it and is
a brain emulation even possible if you
made one would it be conscious or is it
just an empty machine if you made an
emulation of me is that me or somebody
else and I thought these were all
fascinating questions that were overdone
and that hardly anybody had addressed
what would actually happen how would the
world actually change and that fast that
question have all this fascinating
detail and that did in fact successfully
get me to focus and finish a book I'm
told roughly half the people who get a
book contract they write a proposal they
send it off they get the publisher that
says yes we liked your book muzzle and
he's even here's in advance and then
half those people never actually finish
a book so you know I I think it's not a
terrible idea to pick the topic you
would most get engrossed in and actually
finish in do you that that's a crazy
statistic that fifty percent of people
would get that submit the proposal and
then get the go are not even finishing
that well it's a very difficult thing my
my AP English teacher from high school
when I told her I was writing a book she
told me that it's the most difficult
thing you'll do in your life and I
thought that that's a pretty crazy thing
that somebody's telling me even more
difficult than starting a business or
raising a family or whatever so so ok so
what do you think I don't think I agree
with that it's an exaggeration but it
does make a point yeah it's it's it's
definitely a great point what do you
what do you think about then the way
that we're going to scan the brain and
then enable a robotic being to to live
on with it is that going to be through
on eg or what is that going to be like
so the whole point of this analysis is
that you can define this relatively
specific technology of a brain emulation
and then you can think about its
consequences and because the technology
is so specifically defined you can get
really concrete about the consequences
and those consequences don't actually
depend that on that much detail on how
exactly you made it yes so just like if
you are analyzing the future of cars in
1900 you wouldn't necessarily need to
know that much about what their
gas-powered or power
whether they were made out of aluminum
or steel or whether you made them in
factories in Alabama or Chicago yeah but
you mostly needed to know is what a car
looks like yeah okay how much it costs
how fast it goes things like that how
many people are holds and then you could
think about a world of cars and so the
point about rain emulation is the idea
of a regulation is a very specific thing
it's a computer model that acts just
like a specific brain yeah is what same
inputs and it gives the same outputs now
there's a lot of ways that you could end
up making that thing and a lot of
different paths that might lead to that
point but mostly those paths don't
matter so once you have that thing we
can work out the consequence that's
that's a really good way of explaining
it because I can sometimes get really
stuck on what are we doing tomorrow to
make the emulations actually happen and
it's good that you say that what happens
tomorrow for the next couple of years
there's so many different ways to do it
but what is the impact of this on
society just like you were doing with
the car analogy and so what would then
your if if we took the the consciousness
of Robin Hanson we took it and put it on
to 10 robots what would it be what do
you think humanity would be like at that
point when we're having a bunch of
emulations of ourselves on robots in the
world so the the key thing is to imagine
a whole world where this technology is
mature and cheap now the very first
version of the technology could happen
in a lot of different contexts in
depending on who was involved then and
what kind of organization and what
regulation was nearby etc those initial
details could be quite different but
once you think about a world where this
is just everywhere used all the time for
everything you could think of using it
for then I can say a lot more about what
that world is like and so it's not and
most likely wouldn't mat have copies of
me personally I mean it might but that
wouldn't matter very much to what that
world is like so some key points about
what this world is like one is that the
mirros very quickly that is it's easy to
make these robots in factories you can
make them as fast as the factories can
crank them out and because of that the
population of robots can grow very
quickly and that means the population of
robots can grow as fast as the economy
can churn them out and today an ordinary
factory can make as much economic value
as the factory itself contains in a few
months and that suggests that when you
have factories making things that can
then make other factories then the
economy could double every few months or
even faster and so this economy would
grow very quickly and these robots the
number of them would grow very quickly
and because that you can grow robots
even faster than the economy grows the
wages of these robots would fall down to
a subsistence level so that means that
they would have to be working most of
the time just to be able to exist now
that's how most animals have ever lived
how most humans ever lived until a few
hundred years ago so it's not a strange
hypothetical scenario it's the usual
case in history but it's something that
we don't see around so much today and
people have a hard time getting their
head around and it's so close to us
right around the corner and it's really
important to train kids as well to
children to be prepared for that future
so that way they're creative and
adaptive and they're not just easily
replaced by an automated an automation
that can take their work and not be able
to provide for their families and for
the world
so that's a--that's a whole separate
conversation but that's good okay so
that's book 1 book 2 elephant in the
brain so the it's kind of the things
that are taboo that we don't really that
we don't really talk about the things
about how our human mind works at we're
not talking about so well let's unpack
this so as a social scientist for many
decades now I've been struggling with a
lot of social behavior that's just been
puzzling from the usual point of view
things that just didn't make sense
including prediction
markets as ice as we talked about I
started out my career building
prediction markets which are giving
people a thing they say they want and
then being puzzled by their lack of
interest and I've noticed this lack of
interest in a lot of areas in social
science that as we social sciences are
actually able to come up with better
institutions in a lot of areas of life
better ways of learning at school better
ways of getting medicine the doctor
better ways of voting better ways of
doing charity even and the world has
just not been interested and in addition
many of our usual stories about school
or medicine etc just come up against a
bunch of puzzles things that don't make
sense from that usual point of view and
this book is an attempt with a co-author
Kevin similar to explain a lot of these
puzzles as saying we've just been too
gullible to believe people and take them
at the word about why they do these big
things they do so for example people say
they go to the school in order to learn
to learn the material and therefore they
could be better workers and citizens etc
they say they go to the doctor to get
well they say they vote in order to make
for better policy at the nation in the
city etc they say they give to charity
to help people and mostly a social
scientists we have accepted these
standard claims and tried to work out
the details of how exactly they should
go to school or go to the doctor etc in
order to achieve these things they're
saying they're trying to achieve and
we've been puzzled as I said of all
these things that don't make so much
sense and the point of our book here is
to offer the hypothesis that in many of
these areas we are just not honest with
ourselves about why we do these things
we're not actually going to school to
learn the material we're not going to
the doctor to get well we're not voting
in order to make a country a better
place we're not giving to charity in
order to help and these motives are not
the true motives and so we offer a
hidden motive a motive that explains
more of our behavior than this official
motive does and say that this hidden
motive also explains a lot of these
puzzles these puzzles make a lot more
sense if there's hidden motives what
we're really trying to do
so then what are the reasons why we go
to school or the reason why we vote or
go to the doctor what are those hidden
motives that we don't talk about so in
her book we describe the hidden motives
but most of the work is to try to
convince you that they are the hidden
emotive and the way we do that is
through the details of behavior so
starting with school well we might say
school is more about showing off showing
that you're smart and conscientious and
conformist and that makes sense of a lot
of the details of school yeah
and it's those details that we're
focused on to convince you that in fact
that's what we're doing and we say you
go to the doctor in order to show other
people that you care about them and to
let them show they care about you and
that you vote in order to show your
political allies that you're on their
side and you give to charity in order to
convince the people around you that
you're an empathetic person who who just
feels bad when they see people who are
hurting Wow though that's a good that's
a really good start at those hidden
motives for sure what school that one
seems to be especially in Silicon Valley
the whole uncalled sure here it
definitely seems to be true it's uh yeah
it's like signaling to other people that
I'm conscientious versus actually going
and being conscientious in the world by
maybe bringing something of value to the
world and working on that over time what
what else did you guys unpress with you
know it would be interesting to talk
about Silicon Valley alternatives to
school they're also doing a lot of
signaling yeah yeah yeah that's true
it's a Silicon Valley people they've
learned that school is just about
showing off and we really want to learn
things so we're just gonna sit down and
learn actual things and then we're best
basically but it most a lot of the
things that they're doing in Silicon
Valley is a substitute for school don't
look like they're all about learning
either yeah like they're showing off
they're showing that they have
capabilities and other people don't yes
yes what school doesn't but now they're
doing it a different way so then you you
co-authored this book with Kevin Kevin
similar right similar yes what else like
what what other because all these all
these reasons that are these hidden
motives how did you guys end up
collecting data about that and then how
did you kind of unpack that data into
the book so I've waited until relatively
late at life to start writing books I
have work academic articles and blog
posts like that before then and so the
thesis of this book is something I've
been exploring a lot not only in
articles but in blog posts for many
years and Kevin had read some of those
blog posts and liked it and then he
approached me and started to talk with
me about working together on those
topics so in some sense I had already
laid out the basic structure of the
overall you know thesis and these
particular areas but of course there's a
lot of work in the book itself to you
know get all these details clear and
then what were some of the ways that you
ended up collecting this data for
knowing what hidden motives are for
people so the key intellectual strategy
here is to look for puzzles things that
don't make so much sense now academia
mostly ignores them so we didn't have to
do much original research we could
simply go look at the literature and see
what everybody's been finding and
collecting and noticing that are
puzzling and then we could collect those
puzzles and just try to make sense of
them from this overall theory so
unfortunately academia is primarily
about showing off as well it they say
it's about research progress but it's
really more about showing off and so the
most effective way people usually have
to show off is to just do a study that's
very impressive and then throw another
paper on the pile and trying to take all
these papers on the pile and make sense
of them in some coherent way it's just
harder to be impressive Wow that is
whatever you come up with tends to sound
simple and simple-minded and tend to
think well couldn't anybody have done
that
and so if you want to be impressive you
have to do a thing that people won't say
couldn't anybody have done that and so
you have to be doing complicated
difficult studies so what we've done in
this book is the sort of thing you might
say putting anybody have done that and
presumably many people could have they
just hadn't and we want to do it and so
we had to do it but we would unhappy
perhaps if other people had done it
first I feel like a lot of what the
essence of what you're talking about has
to do with innovation and creativity as
well well I think we have hidden motives
regarding innovation and creativity so
creativity is definitely one of these
things we tend to celebrate with lip
service at least in our society and we
don't actually support it as much as we
claim so schools do seem systematically
to crush and discourage creativity but
that's a consistent result of the
educational literature and I think
that's roughly what people want in the
sense that if you think of most
employers with most employees most
employee problems can be framed as too
much creativity too much creativity
about when they're supposed to work or
in what way they're supposed to work how
they're supposed to relate to their
colleagues or how did you treat their
customers you know mostly at theory it's
its variety compared to what they would
like the employees to be doing now there
are some specialized professions where
create TV it might be especially
important like creating advertising or
writing new songs but they're really
pretty small fractions in the economy so
for most employees and most jobs the
employer is not looking so much for
creativity they were looking much more
for consistency and you know reliability
performance you know understanding that
you understand what they tell you that
you figure out how best to do it that
you consistently do it that you don't
lie to them etc so honestly schools do
seem to be set up in order to crush and
discourage creativity they successfully
achieve that and I think that's roughly
what the workplace wants most the time
Ron and I talk about this a lot to talk
about the importance of children and the
importance of them being inspired and
creative throughout their lives and not
crushed by the political and economic
system of our well so imagine that we
had schools and we do sometimes have
schools that took children with a lot of
creativity and potential for inspiration
and let them express that creativity and
be very creative and come up with
creative products and be inspired
through that process and then at the age
of eighteen they're supposed to go find
an ordinary entry-level job and do it
what do you think happens yeah you know
exactly I mean most entry-level jobs are
not places for you would express and
enjoy that level of creativity and you
will not actually inspired if you've
you've learned all through your life
that you should only be doing things
that inspire you what happens when you
have to do something that doesn't
inspire you yeah yep yeah you got it the
most entry level jobs just stifle
creativity most educational systems do
as well and that may not be an accident
but it is the school might be preparing
you for the jobs yeah exactly
we got a long way to go until school
prepares you for creative creativity and
innovation not entry-level jobs yeah
yeah they're looking for obedient
workers and you would too if you were
running most of our businesses in our
world yeah men and then and then those
businesses run on a fabric of economic
and political stability and desire for
growth and so then they need these
workers and they need them to be
obedient and then it's difficult yeah
there's this is a whole system's
thinking redesign so in my book age of
them I talked about the major eras in
history and then the age of em is this
next era that will come after our
current era but the current heir is the
industrial era and past errors were the
farming and then the forging or before
that and a striking feature of the
industrial areas that were really rich
and being really rich in our free time
we can afford an awful lot of autonomy
and self-indulgence and that includes
creativity and self-expression etc but
at work
that's the goose that lays the golden
egg and our workplaces are actually
require less you know more duck have
more dominance and more submission and
more being told what to do than most of
our ancestors would have put up with
yeah and plausibly that's the big
schizophrenia the split in our minds as
being industrial there are people that
at work we have to put up with far more
ordering and structuring the most our
ancestors ever would and school prepares
us for that but that wealth lets us in
our free time be the opposite yep
yeah I think that's so right remember
one of my favorite examples I was when
when Neil deGrasse Tyson wrote an
astrophysicist physics for people in a
hurry he's discussing how when you have
time to look up at the stars and
contemplate your existence that's a
really important time to have and so
many people in the planet don't have
time because they're stuck in the
economic and political fabric they don't
have enough time to go outside of the
light pollution to go lay out and look
at the Stars the same thing goes about
economic theory or about even reading
books or watching videos just learning
in general so I think actually we
industrial people like to tell us
stories about ourselves that are not
entirely true
so we industrial people are rich and
because of that we can be happier that's
pretty clear that is and happiness is
this moment-to-moment evaluation of what
you're doing now and how do you feel
about it so you can eat better food you
can take more breaks you know you can
enjoy more variety of meat movie and
music etc and so we industrial people
are happier but the concept of meaning
is is the same question except looking
at your overall life your whole life and
saying what do I see is the value of
this whole thing and it turns out we
rich people are don't actually have more
meaning in our lives than poor people
poor people actually find as much
meaning in their lives as us even though
they don't have as much free time yeah
don't have as much ability to travel and
see a lot of kinds of read a lot of
things they can't of course like a
sky and when they do they find as much
meaning in that as we do even if they
don't stand the sky as much as we do
yeah that's a whole interesting
conversation about the happiness of
people across different socio-economic
statuses and why and is there something
else Robin that you think is really
important to touch on from your work
that we missed
well prediction Marcus is just one
example of many alternative institutions
and the you know I talked to you about
about say blackmail and and you know
prison and things like that and that's
all part of a larger conversation about
different ways we might restructure our
institutions to have better outcomes and
that's a lot of my life was spent
thinking about those and and then I was
puzzled by a lack of interest and again
this book the elephant and the brain is
helping to understand why we seeing so
disinterested in these things possibly
because we know that we aren't actually
trying for the things we say we are I
also have more research at the moment
thinking about other future scenarios
other than just the age of M scenario
and so I'm working on a grant from open
philanthropy to think about what happens
if we just continue to get more better
software and and if that was the route
that we achieved smart robots through
how does what does that scenario
eventually look like the restructuring
systems for better outcomes I'm really
happy that you care a lot about that and
that you're teaching about that that's
that's a crucial part of our of our
humanity it's analyzing the way that we
interact with each other and and there's
a remarkably we have an interest so if
you talk to people about Trump say or
you know Universal Bacon's income or
other sorts of cheese policy topic you
can get enormous interest in people as
long as the topic seems to fit across a
standard left-right divide or something
but as soon as you start to talk about
larger scale rules or
structures like the electoral college or
approval voting or other sorts of
institutional structures people just
lose interest almost immediately they do
not have much interest in the overall
structure of their institutions they
they're mostly passionate about some
sort of us versus them divided showing
you that they're loyal to their side
yeah that essence of tribalism and
polarization is gonna break down and
then it will be able to have more
nuanced political and economic and life
conversation soon hopefully we're
working on that through projects like
this Robin let's ask you a couple of our
simulation questions what do you what do
you think's gonna happen with this
proliferation of globalization and how
more and more wealth is being
concentrated in just the hands of a
couple people what do you think is gonna
be happening with that in the next
couple decades there's a great book
called the great leveler oh it's about a
year ago and basically says which I
believe that consistently we've seen in
history that inequality slowly increases
until there are great wars revolutions
pandemics collapses of civilization at
which point inequality goes down but
then so do a lot of other things and if
that's the pattern then you should
expect that if we can manage to have
peace and prosperity over the next few
decades
then inequality will also increase and
if we have a big war revolution pandemic
disaster of some sort then you know
inequality may decrease then and that
second scenario is not something you
should be wishing for but it could
happen um and so you should be wishing
for the first scenario where inequality
slowly increases and whatever else you
don't like about inequality you should
like the fact that it tends to go with
scenarios where everything doesn't
collapse and smash but that's disturbing
the first one yes you no peace and no
havoc peace for who
well throw that in even these times of
peace when a new column increases still
most everybody is benefiting even if the
people at the top of the distribution
are benefiting more I mean inequalities
saying that there is a increasing
divergence but still you know most
everybody is better off with peace and
prosperity even if they aren't gaining
as fast as people at the top of the
distribution and you know this this this
is the point at which we should make the
meta point that mostly when people are
talking about grand topics like these
they want to mainly project their values
though mostly these conversations
function our lives as ways that we can
bond with each other and project our
values to each other and we can use
stories and our grand historical arcs as
ways to you know emphasize the kind of
norms and values that we support and
that's just a different agenda than
figuring out what would actually happen
so mostly the things that will actually
happen don't fit that well into a
morality tale they aren't necessarily
the future you would wish and they're
not going to be the sort of things you
can easily you know motivate people to
action through a sermon about they're
just gonna be the way the world is and
so like my age of M is was my serious
attempt to figure out what would
actually happen in this world this
future world of Em's
and many people find the things some of
the things I describe as disturbing and
things they don't like and other people
find other things they do like but I
think it's pretty obvious that this
doesn't fit into anybody's morality tale
mostly when we have stories of the
future we tend to make them close enough
to our morality tales that we can see
that in fact they're indirect ways of
talking about our world which is mostly
what people want to do when they talk
about the future well Robin would would
you also agree though that even though
there might be a little bit of that in
these types of conversations it's also
crucial to be discussing what especially
with people that are leading their
different industries like in Aix and
safety or in bio warfare research that
it's really important to be discussing
hey how do we keep these things in
closed circuits so that they don't
go and them getting become existential
issues or that China in the u.s. don't
combat and kill people in this sense or
kill society off so that's you know that
this is definitely what a lot of why we
talk about this is so that humanity can
prosper through these Fermi filters that
are trying to to prevent us from
actually surviving I mean we should of
course look for whatever problems there
are and try to prevent them but our
desire to tell these grand morality
tales does distract us I think from what
are the more realistic problems and to
focus on what are more comic book
scenario problems the problems that make
the most radix Tories and so I do warn
against that yeah I do think many many
concerns about AI risk are a little more
in the comic book direction I think many
concerns even about you know US versus
China or someone the comic book
direction I think there there are a lot
of real things to be concerned about and
they're just different than the kinds of
things that people talk about when they
want to project their values no Robin
what do you think is the most beautiful
thing in the world where how big a thing
I can talk about I guess I mean so
honestly humans are spectacular
creatures they are amazing creatures and
I think they have a long future so I
think that many people presume that you
know humans won't last much longer the
kind of minds that we have and the kind
of people we are there are so archaic
and so you know stuck in the past and
full of so many in efficiencies and
biases that mostly will just throw them
aside and start over from scratch with
stuff that makes sense and I don't think
that's close to being true I think
humans are these amazing animals that
have you know excel for all the other
animals but even the things we share
with other animals are these amazing
integrated set of mental packages that
will have a long future
so analogy I like to make is with
multicellular animals so as you know
evolution spent billions of years honing
single-celled organisms to be this
remarkable package of little features
that were all really well integrated
together and then it became possible to
have larger organisms of this art size
that you and I are and one possibility
would have been to redesign large
creatures from scratch with you know
separate organelles etc then to take
advantage of lots of scale and scope
economies but in fact what evolution did
is it took all these little
single-celled and it pasted them all
together to make a big creature and that
has enormous in efficiencies that is
each one of these single cells is
basically has almost everything you need
to go function in the wild by itself it
makes all its own stealth and has its
own sensors it's all manufacturing its
own control systems and you could be
vastly more efficient in principle if
you instead of had all these little
cells packaged together with all this
redundancy you made larger systems that
took advantage of scale economies and so
it's a puzzle you should think why did
evolution instead not only start with
all these little cells pasted together
but then stick with that for a half
billion years cuz we're still mainly
little cells pasted together each of
which could survive in the wild I really
I really enjoy that viewpoint I don't
think I've been taught that before I
really like that so why why is did we
not evolved for the cell to become a
super cell and then a super super cell
but rather all this thing together
exactly yeah and so one way to think
about it is evolution spent so long
honing that little single-cell organism
that it was really well honed but it
wasn't very modular and wasn't very
modifiable and that's like a legacy
software system we often have today it
works and it has a lot of stuff in it
but it's kind of hard to change and you
either have to take it as a package or
not at all and so we can think about
that and when you think about the future
you see when we've been writing software
the software we write is a lot more
modular than the software in our brain
so the software in our brain combines
hardware and software it combines
processing in memory it can mixes up
doing and learning it mixes up content
and addresses and then the software we
write we we are very careful to make all
of those things separate and distinct so
that we can modify one without modifying
the others and that we get a lot of
advantages from that of having all these
modularity and the software that we
write but the human brain wasn't like
that and the key reason was because it
combined hardware and software you
really couldn't add a new software
module without adding new hardware that
supported it and so because the brain
could only go so big and had a limited
size you have this very strong limit on
adding more software you could only
really add something if you took
something else away or perhaps
rearranged all the old things in order
to produce produce this new thing as a
side effect of the old things and that's
different how when we write software
today with the right software today
mainly you take a blank screen and you
start writing something new cuz you've
got lots of room to write software yeah
you don't need to like repackage all the
olan necessarily you reuse what stuff
when you can but you can you can also
just start from scratch so because of
that very different environment which
they involved the human brain is this
Marvel of integration but it's not
modular at all and so it's like a
single-celled organism in that sense
they spent all this time honing this
package that's really well integrated
very carefully balanced and and mixed
together but it's not at all easy to
take one part out of it without you know
taking without then have that one part
still work in the same it's just like as
it was with single-celled organization
and so that suggests that in the future
when our descendants have available to
us the software that's in our brain and
other kinds of software together they
may well often use this package of brain
software as a unit just like evolution
used single-celled organisms because
it's there and at work and it's this
Marvel of integration that it's hard to
change and so that's the vision an image
that says that human minds might last a
lot longer than you think
just like single-celled organisms have
lasted a lot longer than you might think
because there's a lot that there's a lot
of power in a legacy system that's
become hard to modify but just is this
Marvel of integration I wonder when we
get to the point of actually not having
a limit on the amount of information
that we can process that we can sense
and process perceive and process because
right now they're so limited I can't
actually even breathe and talk at the
same time I can't smell and hear and
look really a hundred percent at the
same time and so well you can't so we
can I mean thousands of us together can
do these things yeah yeah exactly that
that's that's so cool
what do you Robin do you think we're
alone in the cosmos I mean most
plausibly the cosmos is infinite and
there are just things far far away from
us you know causally disconnected from
us and there's probably other things out
there that are as sophisticated as we
are the more interesting question is is
there anything in our backward
light-cone or you know the backward like
cone of ourselves in a million years
will we have any evidence of anything in
the next billion years that seems
unlikely to me it's possible but
whatever is out there is probably really
far away it's quite unlikely that
there's anything close well it could be
as close as just 10 light years that
would be close yes and I'm saying it's
not that close okay somewhere 10 light
years away we would have other
implications you know so first of all if
one thing's 10 light years away there's
probably lots of other things roughly
that close otherwise it would be very
unlikely that we very rare things would
be that close to each other so that
means there has to be lots and lots of
things out there but if there's lots
lots of things out there this is very
basic puzzle you know most of them
probably much older than we are because
the universe is 13 billion years old
though some of them are billions of
years older than we are and so the
question is how come in those billions
of years they haven't like exploded and
taken over the universe at least in our
area why are they haven't we made it
into there
or they potentially are and they're just
among us and we don't really know that
they are well that's a remarkable
coincidence if the way they want to
remake the universe is exactly what it
looks like when it's dead Robin do you
think that we're in bass reality or in a
computer simulation bass reality I mean
there's just inefficiencies in simulate
I mean simulation you know you have to
have a lot more resources at a base
level in order to simulate resources at
a higher level so most of the resources
you expect to find air at lower levels
include mostly at the lowest level Robin
it's been such a pleasure to have you on
the show thank you so much for coming on
we greatly appreciate it great to talk
to you all thank you and hopefully we
can share more of the work that you're
bringing into the world we'll put links
to your books in the bio hopefully more
people will check them out thank you
everyone for tuning in this has been a
pleasure to have you as well give us a
like comment subscribe if you had a good
time share the content with other people
joining us on patreon help us out to
produce this show we'd greatly
appreciate that and we'll catch you guys
later thanks for tuning in and we'll see
you soon
[Music]
[Music]